[Musique]
dans ces paquets blancs des pains
d’exomax un explosif made in France que
les démineurs vont employer pour
détruire la munition
[Musique]
mais pas question de tout éparpiller
façon puzz les démineurs veulent
provoquer le moins d'éclats possible
donc en fait ici on va mettre de
l'explosif donc on va de 10 g à 30 g là
on mettra 30 g de sucre à l'intérieur ça
cette partie en cuir en fait va avec
l'explosion donc avec la chaleur va se
transformer en under qui va pénétrer à
l'intérieur tout
petit je rêvais d'aider les autres
sauver secourir protéger
finalement je suis journaliste et j'ai
décidé d'aller à la rencontre de ces
hommes et de ces femmes ordinaires qui
exercent des métiers hors du commun
me voilà avec les plongeurs des mineurs
de la Marine nationale
bonjour c'est Christophe Hondelatte là
ça va sous l'eau
je pensais que les démineurs
travaillaient dans les zones de guerre
en Irak ou en Afghanistan cela
travaillait essentiellement sur les
côtes françaises
vous êtes content d'y aller à 22 heures
dans l'eau froide
en mer les chasseurs de mines Français
découvrent quotidiennement des munitions
qui datent des deux guerres mondiales
c'est une valise tout simple la personne
vient fermer son colis
là si elle le lève
explosion
les démineurs sont en alerte 7 jours sur
7 pour garantir la sécurité de nos
plages
[Musique]
on a
mon aventure avec les plongeurs des
mineurs commence ici dans le port du
Havre
c'est nous les gâteaux de la marie
quand on est dans les cols bleus on n'a
jamais froid aux yeux
bonjour monsieur je dois embarquer sur
la Croix du Sud l'un des chasseurs de
mines de la Marine nationale
bonjour Bienvenue à bord très heureux
Richard revire étonnant personnage qui a
commencé sa carrière comme psychologue
dans le civil puis dans la marine avant
de devenir plongeur des mineurs sur le
départ on est sur le départ voilà mais
vous n'êtes pas basé ici toute l'année
pas du tout là c'est juste une escale on
est basé à Brest donc vous venez ici
régulièrement pour qu'on vient ici par
les chasseurs de mines ou d'autres
bateaux de la Marine nationale viennent
régulièrement en escale mais nous c'est
la deuxième fois en un an je crois
dernière fois c'était il y a un an à peu
près afin que vous soyez dans une tenue
plus confortable je vais vous montrer
votre poste
[Rires]
un homme averti en vaut deux je porte
derrière l'oreille un patch contre le
mal de mer au cas où la météo nous
jouerait des tours
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur
je suis allé dans un sous-marin
nucléaire alors depuis
tout me semble confortable on est sur la
taille un petit peu au-dessus
[Musique]
lentement nous nous éloignons du quai
des chasseurs de mines comme celui-ci la
Marine en possède 11 pour couvrir tout
le littoral français
à bord 50 marins dont 7 plongeurs des
mineurs
pour rejoindre la pleine mer nous allons
franchir l'écluse qui ferme le port du
Havre
[Musique]
contrairement à la majorité des bateaux
qui ont des coques en acier nous on a
une coque en résine
c'est un composite donc on peut pas
comme un voilier
parce que sinon ça peut exactement
rapidement faire un truc et pourquoi
c'est en résine n'est pas en acier
l'objectif c'est de d'être à magnétique
pour ne pas faire déclencher des mines
qui justement déclenchent une présence
magnétique d'accord voilà donc d'être
neutre vis-à-vis c'est un petit bâtiment
à haute technologie on n'a pas
l'impression comme ça qu'on à
l'extérieur mais il est d'une très haute
technologie vous êtes venu combien de
fois déjà ici alors en fait les
chasseurs de mines viennent tous les 6
mois entre tous les six mois et tous les
deux ans dans les différents ports
d'intérêt nationaux d'accord qui
présentent un intérêt économique à le
but c'est le port le port et son accès
c'est-à-dire les chenaux également on
vérifie que
les accès sont toujours libres et qu'il
n'y a pas de danger potentiel pour
permettre le transit le transit maritime
d'accord ça rassure ça rassure de savoir
qu'il n'y a rien et de six mois six mois
la situation évolue au point des mines
apparaissent qui n'était pas visi bles
on est dans une région où il y a de
souvent de grosses tempêtes il y a
également de forts courants ce qui veut
dire que des bancs de sable bougent sous
le sous la mer et peuvent à un moment
donné être recouvrir pardon une munition
et 6 mois après la munition peut être
découverte donc un premier chasseur de
mine va passer une barrière voir 6 mois
après il passe au même endroit et il va
voir quelque chose donc c'est ravi quoi
on peut le prendre ainsi
[Musique]
sur marrant comme sensation de quitter
un port moi j'aime bien
Le Havre est aujourd'hui le premier port
de marchandise français
mais ce fut aussi pendant la guerre une
ville martyre tenue par les Allemands
bombardé par les Alliés la mission
consiste à déminer les accès du port
fréquenter chaque jour par des dizaines
de navires
pendant la guerre des milliers de mines
ont été mouillés par les nazis pour
former un rempart à l'entrée des ports
70 ans plus tard si on en croit le
tableau de chasse de la Croix du Sud la
guerre des mines se poursuit
le point névralgique du bateau c'est ici
le central opération
unité 6,
les opérateurs se relaient jour et nuit
pour quadriller la zone au peigne fin à
la recherche des mines qui repose au
fond de l'eau
ça c'est l'objet ça c'est l'engin
pour cela ils utilisent un sonar le
commandant fait une petite démonstration
là c'est mon sonar ça c'est moi qui suis
au dessus de l'eau et ça c'est l'engin
que je suis en train d'observer au fond
ce qui m'intéresse surtout c'est de voir
que quand je vais évoluer on va bouger
on va bouger et je vais avoir un petit
côté et un grand côté
donc là vous avez la forme de l'objet
que c'est quelque chose qui est fabriqué
par l'homme d'accord et dans la mesure
où on a un doute on va donc aller
maintenant
identifier l'engin et c'est ce qu'on va
c'est ce qu'on va aller voir dans un
premier temps on a donc détecté l'engin
on l'a maintenant classifié qu'on a on a
commencé à s'intéresser de manière plus
précise à sa forme et maintenant il faut
qu'on aille le voir parce qu'on n'a pas
moyen de savoir via nous instruments si
c'est réellement un engin explosif ou si
c'est un chauffe-eau ou quelque chose
qui pourrait abidon voilà une voiture
une voiture voilà
le sonar fait apparaître une forme
suspecte au fond de l'eau il faut aller
voir à l'arrière l'équipage s'affaire
déjà
la flèche
ce petit sous-marin jaune s'appelle un
pape un poisson auto propulsé aucun
homme à bord juste une caméra étanche
qui va renvoyer les images de l'objet en
direct
c'est parti génial
donc sans les images
alors pour l'instant
faites la caméra n'est pas encore
allumée
on sait juste dans quelle direction il
va en fait c'est François qui est en
train de donner toutes les directions
d'accord voilà pour l'instant par contre
ce que je peux vous montrer c'est que ça
c'est le bâtiment c'est la
représentation physique du bâtiment ça
c'est l'engin que nous allons aller voir
l'objet que nous devons identifier
d'accord et on va le voir arriver ici
bientôt
l'ombre est en train de descendre là
il est en train de descendre voilà
on dirait un petit sous-marin
3 m ralentir prendre la posture de
sauvegarde
de mettre
1 m contact sur la gauche
et ben voilà
je crois que c'est rond hein
tu fais le tour par la droite
dans le pire des cas c'est un fût
un truc
il y a un organe je vois pas ce que ça
peut être
bon je crois que recules comme ça voilà
parfait essaie de stabiliser l'image là
le commandant pense reconnaître un
anneau de levage caractéristique d'une
mine allemande
on verra bien un cercle d'acier là
ça peut être ça peut être voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes content d'y aller à 22h dans
l'eau froide
j'ai demandé si vous étiez content la
réponse c'est notre travail
vous êtes strictement aucune heure ça
peut être à 3h du matin exactement en
fonction de notre mission du temps qui
nous est donné des prévisions
météorologiques qui peuvent nous limiter
dans notre action on profite de toutes
les occasions pour travailler et là le
notre principal ennemi aujourd'hui c'est
le courant voilà donc en fait on est
obligé d'utiliser un certain créneau
pour pouvoir plonger quand le courant ne
permet de plonger là il est favorable là
il est favorable exactement
allez go
bonjour à tous la plongée ce soir donc
une plongée d'identification 32 mètres
max 15 minutes de durée de travail que
je lui demande pour la plongée donc déjà
c'est prendre des mesures exactes de
l'engin si c'est un engin et ensuite
donc les paramètres d'environnement
est-ce que il y a des questions quelque
chose non c'est parti
drôle de métier qui consiste à plonger
en pleine nuit dans une à 7 degrés avec
un équipement qui avoisine les 50 kg
[Musique]
progressivement les plongeurs
disparaissent dans l'obscurité à 30
mètres sous le niveau de la mer
[Musique]
et là maintenant les plongeur sont sur
l'objet
mais pas nous parler on peut pas nous
parler on voit même pas ce que les
bulles qui sont en train de remonter là
vous voyez si c'est un bidon qu'est-ce
que vous faites vous le laissez
il faut pas se refaire avoir une fois
donc là si c'est un bidon on va
l'enregistrer dans notre base de données
pour que nos collègues qui vont venir
dans six mois ou dans deux ans là il y
avait un bidon qu'on est allé
l'identifié et que donc justement s'il
le revoit parce qu'il est peut-être
recouvert par la vente tout à fait
possible mais s'il le revoit mais qu'il
ne leur interviennent pas dessus
les plongeurs sont de retour
leur combinaison sont censées les avoir
protégés du froid mais à peine revenu à
bord il s'engouffre dans leur douche
intuition est exacte cela veut dire que
350 kg d'explosifs dorment au fond de la
mer au large du Havre
ces plongeurs qui se jettent à l'eau en
pleine nuit attise ma curiosité
leur apprentissage commence ici au
soleil au large de Toulon sur la
presqu'île de Saint-Mandrier à l'école
de plongée de la Marine nationale
monsieur
bonjour
vous allez bien bienvenue à l'école
ça court ça court toujours sur l'école
près de 500 militaires viennent ici se
former à la plongée chaque année la
plupart d'entre eux seront en charge de
l'entretien des coques de navire
d'autres apprendront le métier de nageur
de combat et rejoindront les commandos
marines mais ce qui m'intéresse
aujourd'hui sont les 40 élèves du cours
de plongeur des mineurs waouh voici le
plan d'eau de l'école de plongée et
grâce au ce qu'on appelle les
brise-lames les vieux bâtiments que vous
pouvez voir on a un plan d'eau
relativement calme par tout vent ah
d'accord c'est vieux bateau là tout
rouillé
la mer créé par le vent d'accord
comme de Roanne 34 ans il est
responsable de la formation de ses
plongeurs des mineurs
il dirige aussi la sélection redoutable
qui ne retient qu'un candidat sur trois
combien de temps pour former un plongeur
des mineurs de la marine c'est un an un
an de cours où on apprend à la fois la
plongée la plongée le déminage savoir
manipuler les explosifs et donc dans la
plongée vous avez différentes parties
donc vous avez de la recherche du
travaux sous-marins et qui nécessite un
certain nombre de modules à effectuer et
les types qui arrivent ici sont des
fondus de mer ou pas la plupart sont des
fondus de la plongée déjà
je vous l'achète ce petit endroit je
vous mettrai mes transats c'est super
long
[Musique]
ces hommes triés sur le volet doivent
avoir une très bonne condition physique
car au-delà des mines ils doivent aussi
savoir mener des travaux sous-marins en
tout genre aujourd'hui ces travaux
pratiques option scaphandre
[Musique]
sur la tête
c'est vraiment c'est lourd aussi tout à
fait résister à la pression
on peut descendre à combien avec ça en
profonde jusqu'à 60 mètres
le scaphandrier peut travailler sous
l'eau durant des heures il respire grâce
à ses tuyaux de couleur le narguilé
sorte de cordon ombilical qui le relie à
la surface
ces hommes seront susceptibles
d'intervenir sur des épaves ou de
colmater des réservoirs de navire en
perdition
fermeture de la boîte de conserve
des boules de pétanque
l'exercice du jour sera très concret car
il s'agit d'aller récupérer un morceau
de la toiture de l’école au beau milieu
du plan d'eau il y a quelques mois une
grosse tempête arraché le toit du
bâtiment qui est juste à côté et qui
m'attend ce toit se trouve au niveau du
du Jamon qui est pas disponible
et qui servent qui sert à des fins de
formation
au programme donc de ces travaux
pratiques découpage de tôle par 10
mètres de fond à l'aide de cette machine
une disqueuse capable de fonctionner
sous l'eau facile en surface plus
compliqué en profondeur
et donc là il attend quoi que mais là
qu'une main se tombe pour le prendre
en fait il se rapproche voilà de la de
la bouée qui met comme ça le plongeur
sur le fond il s'est il sait que l'outil
va descendre le long le long du jalon
c'est le problème c'est que en surface
on a vous voyez à 50 mètres 100 mètres
200 m sur le fond au-delà de 5 mètres
vous voyez pas où est l'outil quoi bon
c'est pour ça aussi que les gens
donc ça y est il a récupéré la disqueuse
c'est regarder il enclenche la disqueuse
ça marche bien la machine
au-delà de leur futur mission de service
public dans la formation de nos
plongeurs des mineurs il est surtout
question de leurs objectifs militaires
ma visite se poursuit sur les hauteurs
de Saint-Mandrier où l'école a rassemblé
une bien étrange collection
[Musique]
on entre dans le vif du sujet là
l'idée qu'on se fait d'une mine
sous-marine c'est ça une boule ronde
avec des cornes avec des piques comme ça
donc on appelle un crapaud un flotteur
une corne et qui reliait donc par un
câble qu'on appelle un Haut-Rhin et ça
ce sont des mines qu'on trouve encore
aujourd'hui et qui sont encore dispersés
par des armées exactement que ce soit en
Libye en Irak on retrouve des mines des
mines de ce type de ce type là qui ne
coûte pas très cher à la fabrication et
qui ont un gros impact psychologique en
tout cas
sous la surface elle se déclenche quand
un bateau les touches mais d'autres plus
perfides sont posées directement au fond
des mers
quand on est plongeant des mineurs donc
sur les côtes les côtes françaises
notamment la mine qu'elle en est plus
confrontée c'est la mine allemande type
LMB qu'on va retrouver c'est celle là
tout ceci c'est de l'explosif c'est
rempli d'explosifs c'est l'explosif
lorsque la mine va être déclenchée a
créé une grosse bulle d'air qui va
remonter rapidement à la surface et qui
en fait va venir appuyer un endroit
précis sur la poutre du navire pour
casser en deux le bateau oui parce qu'à
un moment donné le bateau il est plus
soutenu par l'eau
et il finit par casser et il finit par
casser parce qu'il est pas prévu pour ça
quoi
et pour la mise à feu ces mines
sous-marines sont truffés de capteurs
sensibles au bruit et aux remous causés
par le passage des bateaux mais toutes
ne sont pas aussi perfectionnées
voici un modèle de mine artisanal qui a
servi en Irak contre les navires
américains
donc là on a un fût de 200 litres
ensuite 200 litres un bidon d'essence ni
plus ni moins dedans on laisse un petit
peu d'air pour que ça flotte on met on
met au centre de l'explosif voilà et ici
vous avez un système de déclenchement
ultra perfectionné une route bicyclette
et quand un bateau vient toucher cette
cette route bicyclette la mine se
déclenche
et dans cet autre salle je ne suis pas
au bout de mes surprises
devant des mines artisanales comme des
mines en plastique
autant les mines
on pourrait peut-être se poser les
questions pourquoi pourquoi prenons-nous
les missions d'artillerie et en fait
c'est vrai que dans le cas de nos
missions on est amené à travailler dans
l'eau mais également sur la plage et sur
la plage on trouve tout ça
des munitions par centaines chacune bien
spécifique
les apprentis des mineurs passent des
heures dans cette salle à découvrir tous
ces modèles dont certains datent de la
première guerre mondiale
et dans cette vitrine les engins
redoutés par les fantassins les mines
antipersonnelles
c'est des systèmes généralement assez
simple juste il suffit de mettre le pied
dessus pour que ça fonctionne il faut
savoir que c'est des mines qui sont qui
sont faites pour blesser pas pour tuer
pour couper les jambes quoi couper les
jambes parce qu'un bain blessé ça embête
beaucoup plus qu'un mort
[Musique]
visent aussi le moral des troupes
c'est une terrible arme psychologique
[Musique]
ça c'est du plastique c'est absolument
un
détecteurs
métalliques à l'intérieur et il y en a
qui sont spécialement détectables
effectivement et là il y a pas le choix
donc pour des miner son genre de zone on
peut pas utiliser d'apparie c'est tout
seul à la main donc à la sonde c'est à
dire la sonde on fait des couloirs on
crée des couloirs dans les zones où il y
a des suspicions de mines et donc là il
y a des opérateurs qui avancent très
lentement et qui sont dans la baïonnette
toutes ces mines sont normalement
interdites par les conventions
internationales mais dans les faits on
en pose toujours en Afghanistan guerre
après guerre elles ont été éparpillées
par millions Vincent le formateur en
sait quelque chose il en revient
imaginer que le sapeur il va être donc
sur ses genoux pendant 20 minutes avant
d'être relevé et il va donc effectuer le
même geste donc répétitif en permanence
en plus de ça faut bien imaginer que la
personne qui est là elle est en
situation de stress parce qu'à tout
moment elle sait que elle peut buter
contre une mine et il y a déjà eu des
accidents
Vincent a servi 6 mois au sein des
forces armées aujourd'hui pour les
élèves c'était court de détection de
mines en zone inconnue j'ouvre un peu
pour notre disant
en vous écoutant que
vous parliez de manière très technique
de quelque chose qui va l'air très
dangereux
c'est ça très dangereux c'est très
dangereux le risque existe vraiment
vous avez exercer sur quel territoire
par exemple l'Afghanistan et la Libye
et en Afghanistan et en Libye vous avez
vu des gens blessés mourir les démineurs
je dirais 4 il y en a eu quatre sur six
mois pas au sein de toutes les forces
blessés ou tu es tu es
c'est un mot qui faut savoir prononcer
parce que c'est
faut avoir conscience que que le
déminage
on fait pas que s'entraîner et que le
jour où on y est c'est plus d'exercice
et ça ils en ont conscience pleinement
j'ai envie de dire oui puisque les
formateurs comme je suis
ça a été ça a été bien fait on nous a
mis en poste ici parce que on a une
certaine expérience et on a vécu donc
certaines choses en opération
la mine c'est cette tasse à café
vous elle est enfouie donc faut la
considérer comme dessous donc en gros on
fait ça
le piège
qu'on peut vous monter c'est de la
mettre comme ça pas et là je la
déclenche
il y a rien pour éviter ça il y a rien
une heure de travail un mètre carré de
déminé
sur un territoire comme l'Afghanistan on
n'avait pas l'impression de
de vider
la mer avec une petite cuillère c'est le
travail du déminant on sait à quoi
pendant cette heure là non dans l'action
on est concentré et c'est des choses
qu'on pense en amont avant d'aller en
Afghanistan on sait que bon on peut ne
pas revenir mais quand on y est on fait
notre travail
comme Vincent vient de le faire en
Afghanistan les plongeurs des mineurs
prennent parfois main forte à l'armée de
terre même si leur mission essentielle
reste le déminage des côtes françaises
[Musique]
un petit éclat comme ça dans la tronche
il est mort
donc là on voit des piles et au dessus
ça c'est l'explosivité et maintenant on
a un colis piégé
qu'est-ce que tu fais Françoise
pour le contreage
mise à feu
me voilà où GPD de Brest le groupe des
plongeurs des mineurs de la zone
atlantique
il s'apprête à partir pour une plage à
quelques kilomètres de Morlaix un
promeneur vient de trouver un obus de
mortier sur le sable
soyez réactif dans les combien de temps
en fait dans les deux heures on peut
partir dans les deux heures une fois
qu'on a lors d'intervention qui qui
tombe on a deux heures pour se préparer
et partir de Brest donc à chaque tempête
vous êtes quasiment en alerte à chaque
tempête on est quasiment en alerte et
pendant les gros coefficients car sur
l'Atlantique la pêche à pied lors des
grandes marées les gens se promènent
beaucoup et on a des engins qui sont
trouvés régulièrement
cette année plus de 2000 munitions ont
été neutralisées par les plongeurs des
mineurs de la marine mais on pense que
la majeure partie des engins tirés lors
de la seconde guerre sont encore enfouis
un peu partout sur terre et en mer
régulièrement au gré des marais il
réapparaissent
c'est l'homme en serrure rouge qui a
découvert la munition avec le temps elle
s'est fossilisée on pourrait la
confondre avec un caillou
pas évident quand même
à l'arrière et que les ailettes après
une forme ici normalement
il n'y a que face pour l'étanchéité dans
le tube du canon donc là on le soulève
on va mettre en place
nos pneus pour pour limiter les éclats
et là on regarde un petit peu la zone
bon la plage est dégagée il y aura il y
a pas de promeneur mais on mettra quand
même des personnes en amont pour pour
bloquer la zone le temps de la
destruction il s'agit d'un obus de
mortier français de la seconde guerre
contenant 200 g de charges explosives
malgré l'eau et le sel il est resté
parfaitement étanche mais avec le temps
ces mécanismes de mise à feu sont
devenus instables les démineurs vont le
détruire sur place
j'éteins mon téléphone portable
le téléphone doit être éteint on sait
jamais il va y avoir un déclenchement
intempestif donc assez peu de sensible
ça peut être sensible
dans ces paquets blancs des pains
d'exomax un explosif made in France que
les démineurs vont employer pour
détruire la munition
[Musique]
mais pas question de tout éparpiller
façon puzz les démineurs veulent
provoquer le moins d'éclats possible
donc en fait ici on va mettre de
l'explosif donc on va de 10 g à 30 g là
on mettra 30 g de sucre à l'intérieur ça
cette partie en cuivre en fait va avec
l'explosion donc avec la chaleur va se
transformer en under qui va pénétrer à
l'intérieur
et ça perfore donc
on doit détruire et la chaleur à
l'intérieur normalement devrait le faire
bétonner
mais on peut avoir des ratés l'avantage
c'est qu'au lieu d'utiliser un pain de
plastique ou un demi-pin donc 250 g là
on parle de 30 g d'explosifs
sécurité en fait c'est ça économie après
c'est surtout niveau de la sécurité au
niveau des rayons là on a une munition
qui fait aux alentours de 200 g si on
rajoute 250 g on risque d'agrandir les
rayons de sécurité
le rayon de sécurité c'est la zone dans
laquelle personne ne doit se trouver
lorsque les démineurs interviennent et
bien que la munition soit petite le
public devra se tenir à plus de 700
mètres
un gars de chez nous ok directement à la
pointe au fond là-bas comme ça ça
permettra de voilà ça permettra de voir
une approche de derrière est-ce qu'il
faudra tout faire attention on arrive on
a vu qu'il y avait les chalands qui
commencent à tourner autour
les chalands les barges des
ostréiculteurs qui commencent à arriver
la plage n'est pas aussi déserte qu'elle
en a l'air
le groupe des démineurs va devoir les
prévenir par radio car elles viennent de
débarquer leur personnel
pour ne pas perdre de temps les
préparatifs de la mise à feu ont déjà
commencé et ces pneus vont servir de
protection
ça va faire un abri artificiel qui va
permettre de réduire le nombre d'éclats
qui pourraient être projetés lors de
l'explosion
donc là on va effectuer l'amorçage donc
on va venir mettre en place le
détonateur au contact de la charge
la mise à feu est imminente et les
autres agriculteurs s'éloignent pour se
mettre à l'abri tous sauf un petit
groupe qui n'a pas prévu de s'arrêter
j'en ai convaincu un là
mineurs
oui on va effectuer
comment
écouter le monsieur ne vous énervez pas
je ne suis pas énervé je fais mon
travail comme vous là il y a un mortier
qui a été découvert sur une plage
visiblement le pêcheur ne veut pas
bouger
[Musique]
de la gendarmerie ils vont venir et là
vous pourrez pas travailler de la
journée et là et je fais fermer toute la
et là et là je fais écouter monsieur là
je fais fermer la zone et vous pourrez
pas travailler
Mahdi vous avez été prévenu quand donc
je lui ai expliqué qu'on était prévenu
hier soir on est arrivé ce matin pour
intervenir au plus tôt pour éviter que
quelqu'un joue avec et là il va dégager
m'a dit
têtu les Bretons mais pas buté les
barges s'éloignent et les démineurs vont
pouvoir passer à l'action
dans 3
obus vieux de 70 ans mais encore
terriblement efficace
on a limité les éclats
faut-il rappeler que si vous découvrez
une munition historique il ne faut pas y
toucher et appeler la mairie ou la
gendarmerie
un petit éclat comme ça dans la tronche
tu es mort donc voilà
les pêcheurs sont les premières victimes
de ces engins explosifs en 2005 un
navire de pêche hollandais a remonter
une munition dans ses filets qui a
explosé tout en touchant le pont et qui
a fait trois morts parmi les marins
[Musique]
retour à Brest ironie de l'histoire
c'est dans un ancien blockhaus que le
groupe des plongeurs des mineurs a élu
domicile
aujourd'hui ils doivent me montrer une
autre facette de leur intervention les
colis piégés ça c'est un colis piégé ça
tout à fait tout à fait c'est un colis
d'exercices ça fait partie de notre
formation c'est typiquement le genre
d'engin qui ont des terroristes nous au
même titre qu'on apprend à déminer à
neutraliser ses engins pour connaître
l'ennemi on apprend aussi à les
fabriquer d'accord donc là c'est c'est
une personne donc de notre groupe qui a
confectionné le colis avec lequel on va
s'entraîner aujourd'hui d'accord
[Musique]
un attaché case une valise les colis
piégés par les terroristes sont souvent
des objets ordinaires
les plongeurs des mineurs ont tout le
domaine maritime pour champ d'action ce
sont eux par exemple qu'on appelle si on
trouve un colis suspect sur un bateau de
croisière
l'exercice peut commencer
dans cette camionnette de quoi faire
pâlir un apprenti MacGyver
donc ça c'est tout matos
on a divers appareils pour aller faire
une reconnaissance donc on a un robot
qui est ici donc là le robot il va
pouvoir aller jusqu'à proximité du colis
et va nous donner une image vidéo à
savoir est-ce que c'est un colis est-ce
que c'est simplement une valise et donc
à distance donc nous en restant dans le
camion on va réussir à faire une radio
de l'engin et savoir si c'est piégé ou
non pour radiographie le colis les
démineurs ont dans cette mallette un
générateur de rayons X
reste à approcher cette équipement à
l'aide d'un robot et c'est moi qui vais
m'y coller
[Musique]
merci
après ça fonctionne pas radio mais là
pour s'entraîner on le laisse avec le
fil
[Musique]
un gamin
donc là c'est rien de plus rien de moins
qu'une voiture télécommandée tout à fait
vu comme ça c'est simplement je pense
que manipuler la pince prendre la plaque
là où le l'appareil de radio le saisir
avec la pince le positionner devant etc
il faut l'avoir bien normal
surtout que c'est une bombe donc c'est
censé être une
diclops c'est le nom de ce petit robot
il est de fabrication anglaise il peut
descendre et monter les escaliers et je
dois le piloter jusqu'au bateau quand il
va sortir de mon champ de vision ça va
devenir plus compliqué
le robot est équipé de trois caméras
malgré les images qui me renvoient j'ai
tout de même du mal à me représenter les
lieux
comme chez le radiologue je dois
intercaler le colis suspect entre cette
plaque sensible ayant X et le robot
c'est elle qui me permettra de voir ce
que la valise contient
voilà encore
voilà
c'est bon
là on voit des piles
là tout ce qu'on voit en fait bah là
c'est le téléphone là avec la partie
avec son appareil photo et au dessus ça
c'est l'explosif donc tout ça est relié
par des films donc on voit qu'il y a de
l'explosif il y a des clous donc ça
c'est de la frag c'est de la
fragmentation pour faire du dégât pour
toucher des personnes
donc là la question se pose plus quoi là
on avait une valise et maintenant on a
un colis piégé d'accord donc là il faut
intervenir et au plus vite parce que là
il y a danger
[Musique]
pour neutraliser l'engin les démineurs
vont avoir recours à un canon à eau un
jaudeau le but n'est pas de faire
exploser la valise mais de séparer le
dispositif de mise à feu dans ce tube
métallique 15 centilitres d'eau pas plus
la moitié d'un verre propulsé à l'aide
d'une cartouche l'eau atteint une telle
vitesse que la valise va se disloquer
[Musique]
donc c'est la tenue et au D9 et c'est la
tenue mise par tous les démineurs que ce
soit de l'armée de terre
pour rapprocher du colis piégé les
démineurs utilisent cette tenue
anti-éclate conçue pour résister aux
déflagration elle pèse près de 30 kg
Cédric m'aide à l'enfiler
et donc en fait avec cette tenue faut
éviter de tomber parce qu'après pour se
relever
c'est compliqué
ça va
et c'est parti
et donc là tu pars avec les moyens
d'intervention donc là les Jodo les
canons à eau
non il y a pas de gants
dire que les démineurs américains
organisent des courses de vitesse avec
cette cuirasse meilleur temps un
kilomètre 6 en moins de 10 minutes
si toi
ça va c'est crevant j'ai mal au dos
c'est quoi ce truc là
c'est la ventilation en fait là c'est ça
on n'hésite pas à le mettre parce que tu
as vu là sur le parcours déjà quand on
fait 100 m avec on est épuisé et donc là
on met la ventilation
alors déjà là ça fait du bien quand on
ouvre un peu
tout ça tu vas te sentir de suite
beaucoup mieux
je retire le casque et
pour être heureux
si ça pète ça protège vraiment ça limite
les dégâts normalement c'est une tenue
qui est donnée pour résister à 1 kg à 1
m merci il y avait 1 kg mais admettons
qu'on intervienne sur une voiture piégée
qui est chargée d'explosif à plusieurs
centaines de kilos là je viens dire que
si jamais ça explose et que tu es dessus
là tu pourras rien faire mais mais mais
si ça explosé au loin les éclats ça va
te protéger quand même de beaucoup de
choses
on est mieux comme ça bon maintenant à
l'action
bon alors je préviens le chef
d'intervention chef d'incident chef
d'incident de l'équipe d'intervention on
va procéder au pétardement attention
pour un compte à rebours 3 2 1 mise à
feu
combien parti donc là on voit bien la
valise là
le jet d'eau 50 fois plus puissant qu'un
nettoyeur haute pression a entièrement
disloqué la valise le choc a été si
violent que les mécanismes de mise à feu
n'ont pas eu le temps de se déclencher
procédé
le résultat c'est un succès c'est à dire
que tous les éléments sont séparés d'un
côté on a la source d'énergie la pile de
l'autre côté les explosifs et de l'autre
côté le moyen le moyen de déclenchement
donc ici le téléphone
donc là on vérifie juste ce qui est plus
de danger et après on dit à la
gendarmerie de venir procéder à ses
relevé
dans la carrière d'un plongeur des
mineurs les engins improvisés comme il
les appelle sont heureusement rares
l'essentiel de leurs interventions se
passent au large à la recherche des
mines qui gise au fond des mers
[Musique]
retour sur le chasseur de mines la Croix
du Sud
nous avions laissé les plongeurs des
mineurs au moment où il venait de
remonter avec de nouvelles images de
leur découverte
c'est bien une minalement de une LMA
elle pèse près de 500 kg avec le temps
ces batteries se sont déchargées rendant
sa mise à feu inactive peu de risques a
priori sauf si des pêcheurs l'attrapent
dans leur filet car l'explosif qu'elle
renferme est restée intacte
c'est à l'aube que vend débuter les
opérations de pétardement
pour les rayons de sécurité n'a pris 500
kg équivalent TNT
[Musique]
la taille de l'engin impose un rayon de
sécurité d'au moins 500 mètres nous
sommes au large du Havre et les bateaux
n'invitent à proximité une équipe est
chargée de délimiter la zone
[Musique]
qui rentre dans le périmètre qu'on nous
a donné
qu'est-ce que tu fais Françoise pour le
pour le contreage et donc c'est délivré
par paquet de 500 g donc on va en faire
une charge de
5 kg pour la poser au contact à l'issue
et c'est 7 petits explosion de cette
petite charge qui va permettre de
contreminer la LMA qui est sur le front
[Musique]
c'est toi qui importe l'explosie tout à
fait donc là on part on part à deux pour
minimiser le risque le risque d'accident
de plongée on est toujours à deux si
quelqu'un a un malaise il sera monté par
son collègue rien qui part avec les
donateurs l'autre qui part avec explosif
on amène tout ça sur le fond et on va
remonter dans le zodiac dès lever toute
la ligne de tir pour être à 200 mètres
de la munition qu'on va faire exploser
et là sur hors du commandant on enverra
l'explosion et on va voir
alors là on est sur une munition qui
fait 300 kg et qui est à plus de 30
mètres de profondeur du coup on sentira
bien la détonation mais je peux pas vous
assurer qu'on aura une belle bulle
les plongeurs doivent déposer les 5 kg
de plastique au contact de la mine c'est
suffisant pour amorcer les 350 kg
d'explosifs qu'elle contient
[Musique]
mis à peu
elle était belle
elle était super belle
cette mine n'était pas au milieu de
nulle part mais à quelques kilomètres de
l'entrée du port du Havre et le nombre
de bateaux que nous croisons nous
rappelle que la mission des chasseurs de
mines est toujours d'utilité publique
[Musique]
ça ça vous fait un petit souvenir
personnel de votre passage avant de la
Croix du Sud
et une demande dans l'eau une demande à
l'eau c'est une allemande
en fonction des nationalités il y a rien
de scientifique mais on se rend compte
que la qualité de l'explosif ou du moins
de la conservation après 70 ans
peut-être plus ou moins optimale donc et
c'est vrai que les Allemandes
généralement
sont toujours fonctionnent toujours très
très bien alors que les Anglais ce sont
des littés
donc là maintenant on va se diriger vers
un autre écho qu'on a repéré dans la
nuit parce que on a travaillé toute la
nuit et on va faire un lancement pape
pour aller voir ce que c'est et
peut-être que ça sera de nouveau un
engin explosif
et des équipes de la Croix du Sud se
mettent à la recherche de nouveaux
engins
le pape le petit sous-marin jaune
confirme qu'il s'agit de la grande sœur
de la LMA la LMB deux fois plus grosse
que la première
quelques heures plus tard une nouvelle
gerbe d'eau nous prouve que le déminage
de littoral est encore loin d'être
achevée
de la deuxième guerre mondiale et je
savais absolument pas que que la Marine
nationale envoyait quotidiennement des
bateaux pour les repérer puis les
détruire je pense qu'il y a plein de
gens qui étaient dans mon cadre comme
d'habitude je sors coins idiot de cette
expérience que j'ai répété en arrivant
il est temps pour moi de repartir vers
de nouveaux horizons demain ailleurs
j'ai rendez-vous avec d'autres hommes et
d'autres femmes aux vies peu ordinaires